Democrats love talking about Equity but
turns out socialist Bernie Sanders isn't
even sure what it means
how would you differentiate between
equity and equality
well equality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer to that is
coming to think of it you know uh
equality is equality of opportunity
Equity I think is more guarantee of
outcome is it not
okay so which do you come which side do
you come down on
equality well wow what a deep thinker
Dana yeah you could tell this was the
first time I'd ever thought about this
right and also like so I remember
distinctly Greg making that distinction
just years ago when all of this started
and that's what helped me make sure I
always knew the um difference now I've
put on the spot what I have to think
about it for a second maybe because
Equity has become this word that you
hear all the time in fact it's so
ingrained in our society that even Joe
Biden the president has issued an
executive order making sure that there
would be Equity across the entire
government and now people are pushing
back on that they don't want it
necessarily and it turns out guess what
Bernie Sanders doesn't want it either
that's when Joe was just first coming
into office and they handed him a bunch
of papers and he he was just signing
things he had no idea what he was
signing
yeah if you know it's like a couple of
weeks ago because uh the confusion is
intentional they want to I think I said
something I don't remember that we they
want to replace the word equality with
Equity but equality everybody has the
opportunity From Below to excel so the
starting blocks are the same Equity
requires that everyone finish the same
you know which means there has to be
force from above to keep everybody down
which is absolute fascism so it's it's a
if this isn't a subtle distinction it's
like the most important distinction in
the world the only way to unite people
is equality the only way to divide
people Equity that is why you see Equity
being favored by people in power because
it keeps us divided
Judge Jeanine you know I don't know
whether to congratulate them or pity him
congratulate him because you know he
came around or pity him because he
either doesn't remember or he's a liar
so that's all I have to say I don't
think that's scary that whole thing was
scary everybody knows the difference
between equality and Equity everybody I
don't think so I don't think so either I
think how would he not know well he
should he doesn't think about defining
it he has a new book where it definitely
talks about these issues but equality
has basically been wiped out of the
discussion right everything is about
Equity because it involves extra
resources going to people who have
different circumstances if you've
suffered by by force and also by the
kindness of people's hearts too make
sure we can get your place
so I'm not a huge Bernie Sanders fan
because of what happened in the 2016
primary should have dropped out earlier
but I thought he was very Charming in
his Bill Maher interview and he was very
real person so calm a real person and
true to himself and no that's why it's
popular that's why even people like it
and why young people love this 81 year
old yeah yeah I've never heard a
politician say I don't know yeah I know
one of these days a TV commentator I'll
say not at this table not at this stage
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now